an incredible Story of Survival from a
man who survived a plane crash today he
along with dozens of other trauma and
burn survivors from UMC gathering for a
luncheon and eight new sound reporter
Victoria Saha found it and celebrated
their perseverance
a room full of survivors who went
through the unthinkable to get here one
of them 29 year old Hugo Bettencourt who
survived a plane crash back in September
of 2019. I just remember like after the
crash waking a little bit like if I was
asleep or something I just felt the Heat
and I saw a little fire around
my instinct told me to just run outside
bet in court and three of his friends
took off from the Henderson Airport but
mechanical issues caused their plane to
go down he was covered in jet fuel and
Flames bethancourt was in a medically
induced coma for more than five months
here at UMC by the time he woke up it
was a whole new world they tell me you
know there's this thing outside it's
called kobit it's going around
Bettencourt suffered Burns to 95 percent
of his body and had to stay at the UMC
Burn Center for a year once I Saw My
Reflection it
it was like a an eye opening for me
I thought I had just a few scratches on
my head it was just the beginning of his
road to recovery I couldn't close my
eyes at one point I when I was sleeping
I was sleeping with my eyes open because
I just couldn't close but they helped me
I'm told a big percentage of my skin was
made in a laboratory he made he may want
to be present at the annual luncheon for
UMC trauma and burn survivors to show
with strength and support it's possible
to overcome the impossible the Warmness
that I got from them
it it just gave me more reason to be
alive
they made their part and I had to make
my part too for chief of trauma Dr
Deborah cools this is a day she always
looks forward to we treat them when they
are very cute when they just come in
they're injured this is what we live for
this is the best day of the year and for
about in court it's a reminder he isn't
alone in the end it's just like a small
family
now two others died in that plane crash
Bettencourt one of his friends survived
that crash UMC is home to Nevada's only
level one trauma center and verified
Burn Center providing the state's very
highest level of care